breaking news that I don't even know how
to address the daily wire has uploaded a
video our author offer to Stephen
Crowder I guess I officially love Jeremy
border confirming that uh officially
confirming that daily wire is who
Stephen Crowder was talking about they
put this up a couple minutes ago it's 52
minutes long we literally could not just
play the video and watch it during live
show but uh but I mean that's it is what
it is I mean that's it what did the
comment say because that's usually how I
get uh you know
we'll play some of that I don't know if
I can just show YouTube comments well we
can play it for two minutes maybe let's
play it for a couple minutes let's
launch a new initiative call start over
all right our friend Stephen Crowder has
launched a new initiative called stop
big con and in the video announcing the
launch of the project he talked about
leaving the Blaze and all the different
offers that he filled it from other
conservative organizations and what he
thought were the real problems with
those offers and that's led a lot of
people to speculate about whether or not
the daily wire is one of the people who
made him an offer in particular are we
the ones who made the offer that he put
up on the screen and talked about
um at length and the answer is yes that
offer did come from the daily wire I'm
not trying to hide that fact I'm not
ashamed of that fact in fact I think
it's a very good offer but I think
there's a lot of
sort of misconceptions about the nature
of the offer the nature of the points I
think Stephen misunderstood a lot of the
points and so the way we do here at the
daily wire which can be incredibly
transparent you know that we
like to have our members be a part of
the journey we live stream all of our
company town halls for example we just
find that sunlight sometimes is is the
best disinfectant and so with that in
mind I'm going to talk to you a little
bit about how we came to be in
conversations with Stephen how those
conversations ended and and walk you
just line by line through what the
actual document that we sent well so
I'll skip out a little bit we'll only
watch a little bit but I'll jump right
to where we can see he's be addressing
the contract and we'll look at a few of
his points you know in order to properly
address this breaking story we have to
have watched the hour-long video in
advance like with Crowder's video we
don't have the luxury because we're live
now and it's happening but let's play a
little bit and see what he says wood and
so we anticipated that and we said
Crowder will bear the burden of
production including all costs
associated there with on all the content
contemplated herein except on the
quarterly and annual content
contemplated below we'll we'll get to
that part a little bit later it's kind
of a novel concept the quality of the
production will be as good as or better
than is currently existing content
50 million dollars for the initial term
plus 25 million for the renewal term if
extended so that's 50 million dollars
over four years so they were offering
him 12.5 million dollars per year I
don't think it's enough guys because
with inflation the amount of
monetization Stephen has potential you'd
have to offer level three two to three
times that I mean maybe not three times
that maybe two times a year here's my
you know third party statement to both
Stephen crown and the daily wire daily
wire you didn't offer enough money maybe
you couldn't afford to Steven if you
launch your own company you'll make 10
times that
so I I wonder if that's the issue like
Stephen looks at this and he's like 50
million dollars over four years is not
worth it yeah because you gotta
understand that's got to pay his
employees if you could set it off and
cost and overhead insurance and lawyers
and legal fees
tax Fair the burden of production it
says right there then there's taxes and
taxes he's getting 600 Grand a month
bear the bear the bear the cost of uh
well theft well no no no no no it's not
it's not because if Crowder's production
costs are six hundred thousand dollars a
month then he's only profiting 400 and
that he's paying 150 in taxes right yes
taxes are a wild thing dude yeah so uh
that was right there I mean that that's
kind of there we go we now know what the
fee is so the question is meant four
years that's heavy what wasn't the total
like 200 million or something we said
yesterday what was the total we had yeah
we ended up talking about I mean
hyperinflation that's going to be
nothing
I'm gonna have to adjust this for
inflation over the period in order for
account track like that the real
inflation not the fake inflation
government numbers that are actually
fully correct look I know Jeremy boring
I think he's a good dude
um we've talked about potential things
we could work on in deals we could do
and um you know a lot of people were
speculating back when we went and
visited the daily wire in Nashville we
did that week-long thing they were like
oh Tim's going to sign with the daily
wire it's like no I don't think there
was ever a possibility that we would be
a daily wire thing it was more like I'll
tell you guys straight up exactly what's
going on we have uh every every
different way we distribute content is
is monetized in different ways through
different you know Partners some people
specialize in ads only for podcasts some
people specialize in ads only for
YouTube and so you know uh for instance
our podcast side of things like iTunes
Spotify I'm an expert in those spaces
I'm I know YouTube much better and so we
have third parties that work with us so
I've talked to them like hey can you
guys help us with this because we know
we're not doing a good job that's kind
of stuff we've talked about and being
able to go to a company like the daily
life fire
and literally talk with their CEO and
have him just be very candid and like I
got to tell you like of all the business
meetings I've had the easiest one was
with the daily wire because it
ultimately ended like okay well you know
maybe we can't work on this now but
we'll figure something out we'll hang
out sometime good good hearing from you
man I've worked with with the first
contract I was ever offered was from uh
well I'll leave I'll leave I'll leave it
I'll leave them out of it it was a big
agency it was one of the big big talent
agencies they represent people you've
heard of on Fox News and they give me
like a 70 page book contract to read and
I'm looking at my and I'm like this is a
joke right and it's like no no don't
worry it's standard and I'm like dude
you come to a guy who's like an
up-and-comer coming a comer in the space
it was a five-year contract I know I
know the game they were playing it was
going to lock up everything it was going
to own me for five years and leave me
with nothing and I couldn't afford to
hire a lawyer to read that many pages so
I threw it in the trash and said have a
nice day not interested in wasting my
time that is almost every negotiation
with every company I've done the daily
wire was was like literally I sat down
with with Jeremy and we talked about how
could we how we could do things and I
thought it went went well that being
said these contracts don't work it says
like right here you can see right here
Crowder will deliver a 1.5 hour long
ladderworth crowd or audio show of
equality and the kind of blah blah blah
they have to say that because they don't
want to sign a deal with you and then
have you drop the quality to save money
but then all of a sudden if you're
someone like Crowder and you're like you
want to own what you want to own
everything and they're like I'm not
going to give you 12 million dollars per
year without the right to distribute the
content to make money on it you just
can't do these deals man yeah these are
old archaic contracts that don't make
sense Ian made that point yesterday and
it was a very good point my question is
how many eggs were the daily wire uh
Team are going to be paying Crowder with
is that in the contract as well because
that's the commodity that I think is an
important one during these very
difficult in inflationary uh times let
me play a little bit more Clay Bennett
uh Blaze well he would still do that
same kind of concept 30 minutes of the
show would now be behind our paywall uh
Crowder can bank or pre-record a limited
number of episodes upon our approval and
reasonable discretion
um days without new original episodes
will be scheduled in advance subject to
our reasonable approval what's this
about holy I like Crowder
you know in addition to his four weeks I
think I think I think the daily wire
should just publish a link to the
contract yeah for sure because he's
already shown and he's going through a
whole bunch of stuff and I think Crowder
opened the door when Crowder showed that
portion he actually said you know don't
make me bring the receipts right so the
daily y responds with okay let's go
through some of the contract at this
point I'm like okay dude just like
publish it yeah what are yours because
like the fee being released is huge
um
here's what here's here's what I think I
think Stephen Crowder
man here's here's the challenge Joe
Rogan's deal what did it turn out to be
like it was initially reported as 100
million and then it was revealed later
200 million we don't know how many years
that's over or what it does include is
it stock or things like that I think I I
don't know or is it the old episodes too
or is it the entire podcast is it the
first episode
that's a lot yeah got them off the pro
like Joe Rogan had the number one spot
on iTunes the premier podcast platform
and he sold that that makes sense you
know Spotify says look we're gonna give
you two million dollars over X years I
don't know how many years it was I'd
imagine it wasn't four but it could have
been and so you imagine Joe's then
getting 50 million bucks a year for his
show that's the crazy thing Stephen
Crowder's show is he's not Joe Rogan but
I mean come on like 12.5 per year 50
million over four years he's he's not a
quarter of Joe Rogan he's half or more
and considering what we're talking about
arguably comparable Joe Rogan reaches a
certain kind of audience and he's huge
we get it but Stephen Crowder motivates
people more I'd be willing to bet that a
Crowder ad read will sell 10 times more
than a Rogan ad read no no offense to
Rogan but Crowder is a culture
Crowder's a culture Warrior you know
when he goes out and he says guys you
gotta get this thing because these are
the companies that Believe in Us people
are going to be like yes when Joe Rogan
says I shave my balls here's the thing I
use some people are going to that's cool
I'm like on it I like on it Fleshlight
that he was supporting looking at it
from daily wires perspective they're
putting 50 million down they want to
make profit on this too so they're
anticipating yes it's worth at least 50
million and then probably at least 50
percent on top of that you know and
that's where you know ballparking like I
I agree with you I think what you know
being independent in this space is the
best way to do it I think it's the best
environment for a true creative I think
it's the best upside on the
profitability and there's so many
business opportunities being created in
this sector which is relatively new
really has just blossomed in the last
two to three years so you know Crowder
might be looking at okay what am I
looking at the next two or three years
but he's gonna be doing this for 30 40
years potentially if he wants to here
here's here's here's the thing about any
of these deals
couple years ago we had one of the big
networks come to us and say let's do a
deal and we were much we were relatively
smaller but you know we haven't grown
that much like we've grown a lot but you
know in terms of Revenue and stuff where
as a company we're doing a lot better
but they basically all say like we'll
own it everything you do we own and I'm
just like not interested because I'm
gonna do a three-year deal with you
right that's what you're asking you're
at you're coming to me saying three
years and at the end of it you walk away
you keep your brand you keep your name
we keep everything else I'm not
interested in doing that I already have
I already have my own channels I already
have my own brand I already I already
already have a membership platform why
would I just give that to you in
exchange for what comparable amounts of
money that's a stupid thing as you said
Rogan it's like a new uh a new
entertainment environment it's a new
business model opportunity so many
different ways to make money in the
space that and now the parasites have
come out is what not I'm not calling
anyone particular I'm just saying the
parasitic nature of business has aroused
it happened in 2006 I was doing internet
YouTube videos and like once I got like
10 000 no no like once I started getting
like it's a thousand fifteen hundred
views per video I started getting emails
and messages hey we can we can get take
your channel to the next level hey hey
hey hey hey hey I want to make some
money off you hey say this thing I want
you to say and like let me
I want to play this clip I think he
talks about the fee here this is the
most important part now here's this
section that I know Steven was very
offended by
um and I think he I think he
misunderstood and therefore
misrepresented C reductions
there's a different fee reduction for
all those kinds of contents we created
daily content if he fails for any reason
to deliver 192 episodes of The Daily
Show
or if he fails to include the ads that
we agreed to or the promotions that we
agreed to in those episodes then we'll
give a hundred thousand dollar reduction
every time what's that about well again
you can't pay someone
any amount of money but you certainly
can't pay them
an unimaginably huge amount of money for
their show and then not get the show so
what this is saying is you don't have to
produce a show every day you don't have
to produce 260 or 250 or 240 or 230 or
220 or 210 episodes a year you got to
produce 192 episodes a year you can film
some of them in advance you can stack
them up all of that's contemplated in
there you could shoot on a Friday so
that you could take two days off next
week
but if you don't give us 192 episodes we
we can't pay you the same amount of
money as if you did give us so hold on
there a minute if it's 12.5 per year
with 192 episodes that's 65 000 per
episode not a hundred and so the fee is
bigger than the fee is the revenue which
which is a weird payment structure so
that that seems kind of uh uh punishing
it you you would typically want to do a
payment structure that's more you know
affirmative like hey after every 10
episodes we will pay you blank so you
kind of truncate it into smaller it
sounds like they're doing such a big
Advance up if you're doing if you're
right if you're doing a guarantee of x
per year I understand what the daily
wire is trying to do but I will push
back and say
what the contract should say and they
could be doing the big ask it could be a
trump move where they don't want Crowder
to negotiate a net benefit they want to
break even so they say 100K expecting
Crowder to come back and say no no Pro
rate divided by the fee for the year so
it should say in my opinion that's how I
do that I'd say uh what are we paying
you 12.5 a year 192 episodes okay
um any episode you miss we deduct one
unit division into that fee so whatever
that breaks down to 65 000 you miss an
episode or you miss an ad read we will
we will remove 65 from your from your
your minimum your guarantee basically we
are buying 192 episodes for 12 point
12.5 per year if you don't deliver one
we prorate you but the argument is it's
the it's the the library itself is worth
more than the sum of the parts so the
one show by itself then you have 20
shows all they're worth more than 120th
each because they create you know so I
can see why let's up the well we'll let
uh Jeremy continue because I want to cut
him off if he's going to make important
context to part of the conversation 192
episodes so this is just yeah you give
us 192
times 4 minus 1 then out of your 50
million we're hitting minus 100 000.
Stephen said that this is not fair that
he he said 192 times 4 minus one then
we're taking 100 150 million yeah yeah
look man
that doesn't add up yeah what's 50
million 192. it's going to be 65 104.
yeah because you know basically what it
breaks down to so that doesn't quite
quite add up
um that being said the daily wire
offering a steep fee as a means to say
like don't drop shows I also understand
they don't want to do a deal with make a
guarantee and then one day Crowder says
well you know I don't lose anything if I
back out on this deal right if if if he
and I do a deal and then Ian's relying
on me to make a profit
and there's no penalty other than I
don't get paid for the day but Ian gets
screwed over well that's going to suck
so again I think it may be reasonable to
say something like 70 000. so you will
get a 5 000 hit on your overall minimum
because we don't want to create an
opportunity for you to just be like I
guess I'm not going to do a show today
because I don't feel like it you know
what I mean you know what I think
they're factoring into that is their
costs for their production and their
licensing and distribution it's a
hundred thousand so 65 is for Crowder 35
is probably what they estimate that's
actually a really good point that's
actually really fair point uh in order
to distribute and make money off of what
they're buying from Crowder they're
going to have their own crew doing all
of this stuff as well editing right uh
and and that means if they've got 300
employees and they've got you know 10
allocated to proper promotion
distribution making Clips uploading the
website monitoring for bugs doing the
back end stuff because they're a lot
bigger
maybe maybe 100 does make sense I mean I
certainly think uh it you factor that in
and you factor their loss of profits in
so they're basically saying we're paying
you 65. we're also going to lose 10
because we can't do our sales our
employees showed up to work our
employees showed up also the people who
bought the ads are going to come to us
angry so that's actually an interesting
point Fair Point you know I don't think
we can go through this whole thing
though so I don't know if there's any
other I'm going to do it later it's a
tough deal you know what I I I I'm very
curious to see what Crowder says if
there's anything else but to me this
just seems like business tough business
uh it's a lot of money there's there's
high stakes and people want to make sure
that their Investments are protected so
I'm not necessarily anti-daily wire on
this but
um I I am curious I'm sure there's just
a 50 minute video Crowder's got his
whole you know experience going through
this so there's a lot more to this I'm
sure this is actually really awesome
that this transparency is incredible
right it's so good for the business
environment I mean the the here's a
challenge for the daily wire a lot of
people are saying like you should have
said anything they were he didn't
mention you bro everybody was saying it
was a daily Wire yeah and and that and
then now the daily wire has no
opportunity no they they're basically
have no choice and hey it's good
promotion but Crowder was talking about
how not necessarily these figures wasn't
it that they uh were like partnering
with the bad guys or something well his
complaint was that uh let me see if I
can actually find the part where he
he'll talk about it I imagine he said
the big con and that they're working
with uh Big Texan here we go
look if Crowder is boycotted if Crowder
is boycotted or dropped by more than 50
percent of his then extant advertising
partners that is
if 50 of the money that he's making from
advertisers is suddenly gone and we're
not able to replace that Revenue within
90 days
then his fee will be reduced by 25 until
such time as the ad Revenue has been
restored for a period whoa that is
giving Crowder free money that's insane
think about that for two seconds if
Crowder's revenue is dropped by 50 50
from his advertising Partners plural
went on if it's dropped by more than 50
percent of his then advertising Partners
they will reduce his fee by only 25
which is what 250 000 a year-ish well
potentially so it's potentially
advertising Insurance it sounds like but
50 of his Revenue may not necessarily
equate to his fee so this is
making more than 250 000 a year in
address what does AD Revenue compared to
the fee you know 25 of I see it so so it
it could be they don't include
membership Partners but they're also
giving him 90 days meaning if if
something happens that's a nice grace
period three months to figure it out
that means Crowder could be making half
the revenue for three months and they
still won't charge him a fee or a
penalty what I don't like are floating
it makes him rely on advertisers still
which is I think he's trying to get away
from that being rely on advertisers and
if if his contract forces him if if I
was going to do a deal with someone I
would say if your content gets boycotted
your fee will be reduced commensurate to
the amount of money lost from those
boycotts like and that's the crazy thing
like
we share the risk well or yeah I mean we
can give you a guarantee but if there's
no money coming in like there's no
guarant there's no money to guarantee
you that is to me like a little bit of
afloat daily wire you know they're
they're almost a creditor in that
instance I that that that came off as
like
a a surprisingly gracious I didn't ex
here we go here's the important part I
didn't expect the daily wire to offer
something like that to be honest part or
not and then we lose the business as a
result and now no one pays Stephen
anything and no one releases Steven's
content he has to go build it all from
scratch in crisis
ban the Crowder content cannot be
released on any of the major platforms
because of its content being banned from
those platforms
then we'll reduce the fee of YouTube 20
if Apple 20 if Facebook 10 is Spotify
10. same kind of concept
if the content simply cannot appear and
therefore cannot not only be used for
marketing cannot be used to grow the
brand also can't be monetized or we
can't pay them the same as if it was if
you're making 25 of your money on
YouTube
uh and now YouTube is permanently gone
we you can't make that money anymore
it's not punishment this is really what
it comes down to Steven's you can pay
them philosophy seems you just would run
it at a loss if you did you can though I
deserve to be paid millions and millions
and millions of dollars
whether my show drives the revenue or
not
I got I gotta pause right there and say
Jeremy yeah that's the point the reason
Stephen Crowder wants to do do a deal
with you is so that you assume the risk
and he doesn't the the only and that's
why I'm saying these contracts don't
make sense because what Jeremy is saying
makes sense from Jeremy's perspective
but it doesn't make sense from from the
perspective of anybody who wants to do a
deal it's it would be like
it would be like someone saying you know
Luke I'm gonna buy your RV off you
and then if it breaks you I'm not giving
you the money
like well well hold on they always break
no but my point is my vehicle put in the
contract Crowder's basically saying like
I don't want to worry about this I don't
want to worry about the risk the revenue
you figure it out and then Jeremy says
okay but if it breaks we're not going to
pay you I mean I think that's reasonable
if you buy it or you don't if Stephen is
wants to offload the risk then he's
offloading a huge chunk of the income I
mean that's the risk is a big part of
why he's worth so much is because it's
on his shoulders the deal can't exist
this is what I was saying like when I
said Crowder was right about everything
with these contracts like and and I like
the daily wire guys I think Jeremy's a
good dude and I think Jeremy is doing
right as a business but it doesn't make
sense for Crowder to sell
what he has
to basically hear you're in the exact
same position we don't assume the same
level of risk like you're you're gonna
you're gonna face the same risks you're
if you get a strike you don't get paid I
do think there's some guarantees like
I'll point this out
if he gets banned by YouTube the only
dock his fee by twenty percent
that that's actually
I mean that that structure right there I
think is actually really great
that's that that is the daily wire is
doing some good things YouTube
is a larger portion of Revenue and
viewership so when it comes to direct
sponsorships you'll make more of a
YouTube read than a than a than a
podcast read to a certain extent but
podcasts in the long run will make more
money it's it's it's hard to explain
like
you get more views on YouTube so you can
sell a package for more
equal to the number of views though the
cpms are lower so for them to break it
down this way actually seems like there
is some stuff being taken off Crowder's
shoulder in terms of uh I wonder what
his angle is when he says you know
they're basically partnering with big
Tech to take this is it yeah and so he
gets dot he gets he gets he gets
penalized if he breaks YouTube's rules
but is he thinking that like daily wire
is gonna like sabotage him so that they
just may are able to pay Crowder less
like it he seemed very angry about and
I'm just wondering what in it to me this
doesn't strike me as this is them
partnering up with big Tech to take time
yeah he was kind of he was kind of
alluding to that we definitely need more
clarification for it because let's be
honest here uh you know the daily wire
and Ben Shapiro do get suggested a lot
on Facebook if you look at the most uh
shared links from Facebook it's usually
the daily wire and a lot of people are
asking that's kind of it's kind of weird
you know that's kind of you know what's
going on here and then we have these
statements by Crowder so you know
there's obviously a lot more questions
here Zuckerberg's a huge conservative
turns out I don't know nah I I have far
more questions than answers this stuff
you know working in Hollywood contracts
uh there's no there's no market Standard
you know especially in this burgeoning
industry so it's really fascinating to
see a little bit of the inside
information because now you can say all
right I'm this x percent compared to
Crowder he was getting it gives you a
chance to but people are making this up
as we go you know what what is a Marcus
Center for a contract it's all black box
in Hollywood dude I I I know everybody
is about people commenting in the on
that video saying I stand with Stephen
Crowder and uh
I just feel so bad for the daily wire
because they're not bad people and
they're trying really hard they're not
this like the hardest of culture
Warriors like we or Crowder are but I
don't think they're bad guys who are
doing bad things I think Candace is hard
culture culture Warrior like you and
crap that's true that's a fair point but
Jeremy's he's all big I mean he's not
all business he's in the business
and what is a woman was extremely
important that was a tremendously
powerful and very important thing but
when you say daily wire you got to talk
who owns daily wire it's it's Jeremy Ben
you know and Jeremy's in the business
aspect he's not a culture Warrior but I
want to clarify when I said I feel bad
for him I don't feel bad necessarily
about this like dude you offer a big
name a contract that pisses him off
don't be surprised if they come and they
get mad at you about it and they can wag
around and be like this is a terrible
contract I feel bad because how do you
compete with the likes of Disney
how do you do it yeah it's like Disney
will get people to sign up no matter
what because they own Flubber because
they own
Decades of American cultural history and
the daily wires got to build it and it's
probably just 10 times harder than
managing Disney
I mean look at look at what they're
doing with all the Marvel stuff
regurgitated remakes
etc etc and the daily wire has to
navigate the space and you want the
worst possible thing is
what made what was the big hit for the
daily Wire yeah what is a woman that
Matt Walsh document and what about Gina
carano's film
I didn't see her on the Prairie yeah so
the issue is the daily wire is trying to
break the cultural mold take the space
and to an extent it's working I mean
they have a million paying monthly
members so they're building it up
they're what 20 times smaller than
Netflix is but did we hear about how
tremendously amazing Tara on the Prairie
was did we see groundbreaking virality
no but what does a woman did the problem
is what is a woman is political that
means the daily wire is still trapped in
their pigeonhole and if they're going to
have the cultural impact that we
actually need them to have they need to
get bigger hits in different areas that
are very very difficult to do they need
their own Mickey Mouse I will say just
looking at that contract assuming that's
the primary contract that's a very
simple like simplified contract they get
far more verbose far more carve outs and
exceptions and preconditions so uh again
I'm not taking a side on this because I
don't have enough information
um I I'm definitely very curious to hear
what Crowder's perspective is though
someone a super chatted remember Crowder
is bringing in 300 000 Subs at 10 bucks
a month that's 36 million a year Crowder
uh let me see sorry kind of scroll
Crowder wants band protection and is
wanting a distribution partner I I agree
I don't I don't know that we can
guarantee crowd will bring in 300 000 I
think it's possible more than that I
think from a contract perspective if if
someone came to me and said look you do
it you know if like Ian came to me and
said bring me on the show and I
guarantee you 10 000 new paying monthly
members I'd be like you can't guarantee
me that like I can look at your metrics
and then make and then make a bet and if
I'm wrong I lose a lot of money I don't
know if I'd want to do that yeah there
would have to be some cash incentive if
I was going to guarantee a subscriber
buy something I also do think from a
practical standpoint Stephen Crowder
likely will bring in 300 000 to 500 000
new paying monthly members at 10 bucks a
month in which case uh
yeah this contract's not good you made
an interesting observation that he might
be concerned that with the 20 if he gets
banned off YouTube 20 if he gets better
that if daily wire is in charge of the
edit and the the post that they could
put something up that would put them in
a light that would get him banned and
then be able to cut his salary by 20.
he's very nervous about their
affiliation with big tech and and that
to me has not been addressed in this we
saw the provision but it to me it
doesn't really where where's Crowder
getting he was very upset very uh
nervous about I I I I don't see it yet I
don't know what he's focused on crowder
needs to do his own thing
because like I said the other day I
think Crowder would make 10 million
bucks a month people are saying 36
million a year I disagree uh based on
how big Crowder is based on what he was
able to do with rumble on uh on with the
midterms
they had 10 no he had like uh what he
had like seven or eight times the amount
of viewers we had yeah so like I think
we I think we ended up with I don't
remember we had 60 70 000 he had 500 000
on Rumble special shout out to Dave
Landau that that
that lovable little lovable garden gnome
I love you brother I love you man he's
so awesome dude I think Crowder should
launch his independent mug Club
and uh 10 bucks a month honestly it
might need to be a little bit more than
that because because of costs these days
like no seriously like bandwidth costs
especially if you're gonna do anything
live but 10 bucks a month probably
probably would work
I think you'd probably get between 300
500K
probably making five million a month
with no ads yeah none just off subs yeah
yeah back-end hosting is expensive these
are the numbers that the contract should
be working out we're going to cover
hosting like we mentioned that last
night like do Tech contracts with these
with these actors these performers so
that you cover their back end
expenditure and costs I I I I I'm I'm
doing the math in my head right now I
think 300K is a good estimate it's a
good estimate so what needs to happen in
this contract is Crowder should probably
say here's here's what I would do I go
through all of it and I would say oh you
want all these things my answer to you
is yes and we're going to add one
paragraph I get 80 of memberships
and then they're going to go uh well I
don't know about that and I'll be like
okay here's what I'll do I'll take a
hundred percent of my memberships and
I'll make my website thanks for your
time yeah right
which I don't know why it doesn't just
do that I mean they have a massive
distribution platform well it's because
he's also been like demonetized on
YouTube for like how many years now
here's been on for I don't know here's
where's what I can say career around
three years if I I I I know this to be
true
that if we did some kind of partnership
with the daily wire this show would be
10 times bigger in half the time we
would have like there there the daily
wires I think 20 times bigger than we
are they have people all over the place
they have more fans than we do they have
more connections more celebrities who
visit their offices they have their own
Talent roster if I did do a deal with
them in any capacity and they were able
to be like here we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna change your show
it would just like bigger studio built
by a more professional company faster oh
they got The Swinging cameras that come
through right like we're we're a company
here at timcast and we are every day
trying to learn
and and navigate and and Forge this path
forward meaning like oh man we had we
have hiccups all day every day and it's
just like constant headaches and I
talked to Jeremy periodically and then
he's like he's like well my friend just
just know that always gets worse and I'm
laughing I'm like he's right because I'm
like you know we're we're working on a
project right now with the daily wire
crew a music project I don't want to say
too much about we're really excited and
uh so I've been talking to him and then
you know I'll mention like oh we had
this problem with this financial thing
and then he laughs like I remember we
had that yeah not 20 times the worst and
so I'm just like if if we were able to
get a company like them to like just
even consult it would be huge if we were
able to have their resources in terms of
booking it would be massive we would
have bigger celebrities bigger names
bigger connections yeah in no time but
you know look we're our own company we
do our own thing and there's there's
it's it's impossible to just you can't
just make something like that happen
same thing as true with Crowder why
would Crowder do a deal with with daily
wire it's like you're saying their
production resources distribution and
access is so massive that it it would
substantially benefit Crowder however
as for who Crowder is he doesn't need
them
he can make his own website it will just
be harder it will take longer but he
will make substantially more money
yeah even Rush Limbaugh worked for
another company what Company Salem media
I believe the whole his whole career uh
at least at the end I believe I'm just
jumping on that but like I mean Candace
Owens one of the biggest names and you
know she's generally worked with Prager
and and turning point and now daily wire
I mean it's just it's just different
business paths and it's just it it how
how your lifestyle meshes with that how
you're you know kind of vision and your
creativity I personally I can't work for
anyone I I would rather take less money
and just if I'm not going to work that
day I'm not going to work that day you
know like that's on me but if someone's
telling me hey you got to do this you
gotta [ __ ] I can't do it at this point
so yeah I'm the same way like why take
orders from somebody it just doesn't
make sense I've been through that at
this stage I'm working at for Tim the
Tim cast Corporation and it's like it's
a little emasculating at times like I'm
like damn I can't just
promote I can't just publish a new show
like it's owned by Tim cast corporation
which is reasonable I think because I'm
work I'm getting paid by team pass
Corporation and I can always end the
contract you know but like but I think
there's a time place because the social
capital gain outweighs the value of
anything I could do on my own at this
stage of my career but but Ian that's
technically not true it's it's true in
the sense that anybody who works for
timcast has an agreement that anything
you make related to our business we own
that means what do we do here we do
political commentary we do YouTube
videos we do social media posts we make
music
we're making video games now and you
recognize that we're doing all of this
multimedia stuff
however it also states that at any point
you want to do something you need only
tell us
that's it true yeah yeah that's in the
that's in contract also so like the
point is we can't have people work here
who are going to be like I'm going to
make music for you and then we go
awesome and then they come out with an
album it goes double platinum or
whatever and they're like well I made
that at home I think because we'll do we
hired you to make that standard
Hollywood procedure yeah it deals with
major Studios like I can't say them but
uh they basically have first look they
own any movie you make subsequent if
you're like the if you're a first time
director for a major Studio they own
your ass because like we kind of brought
you up on the map and I'm not saying
that but like uh and but you know I will
say about Jeremy boring and Ben Shapiro
they don't work for anyone you know they
started that company and just built it
up I think you guys are outside looking
at you guys are crushing it also so
first look is a good way to put it the
way I describe it everybody is
everybody has to have an agreement that
if you're working here you're working
for us however I don't want to own your
music man I don't want to own your book
because of our our contracts with other
companies you just have to come to us
and be like I'm going to write this book
it's nothing to do with you it's me I'll
be like okay you don't know all right
I'll write up contract saying we have no
rights over the book They're produced by
Russell you're good but there's
something in the back of the ma of my
artist's mind where it's just knowing
that I have a contract signed that is
owns my work in the until I override it
is there it's like it messes with me but
I have to weigh the value like the value
of to be honest I would do this show for
free anyway like I you know I've even
talked with you about like I don't need
the money I'm not here for the money I
don't care about the social capital far
outweighs the dollars in my opinion
um so I'm constantly doing the weight of
like everyone's getting on your contract
decision you know what's best for your
life and what you want to do I I I
remember thinking when I was younger I
was like oh you know I'm gonna start a
business and I'm going to scale it up
and then it's gonna be a multi whatever
I don't even want to do that you know
quality of life I I I don't think of how
many had it you know do you really just
want to be consumed by your business all
day every day I actually want some time
to hang out with my wife and you know
future kids so it's also like I don't
want to work all day every day I don't
want to compete with them you break my
voice like me and Tim both make cartoon
like we were funny act we do acting and
stuff like I don't want to compete I'd
rather work together I don't want to
compete with Jeremy I don't want to
compete with Steve Crowder I want to
work you know unified you know kind of
create art together like we don't have
any kind of contract anywhere near the
level of what the what the daily wire is
offering like the that massive lighting
out terms or like whatever like we don't
have anything yeah there's no time
period on the contract there's literally
nothing in any agreement anywhere that's
like Ian if you get as banned we're
going to dock your past like no hey
anyway you know like get mad about it I
suppose but also it's like there's no uh
no time commitment which is Ultimate in
this rapidly changing entertainment
structured environment like putting
someone on a three-year freaking leash
is insane in my opinion well there's a
reason for that and it's what we were
talking about the other day right so we
have no no term uh contracts with
anybody who works here and that's a huge
risk on our end because I'm you know I
joked everybody I'm a communist so it's
like
if if we invest in you as a as a
personality and then you quit on us
we've just lost all of our investment
you know and that's why nobody wants to
do that that's a reasonable position
though that's again that's standard in
Hollywood that's like a computer we have
we don't have a term for anybody like
Ian could leave the show whenever he
wants to make his own thing that's like
the log out right now quite generous the
robot brain is if I were to lock you in
then I will benefit in the future but
the reality is I love you more as a
human for respecting me and my freedom
and and I would gladly hang out with you
I'll tell you I think I'm better at
business than all these people if you
don't want to be here you should not be
here and I do not want to keep sinking
money into a person who's trying to
leave yeah now that's wasted money so
all these these big companies they're
like look if I'm gonna invest 10 million
dollars in you I need to know that I can
monetize that for four years or whatever
make money of it my attitude is hey look
I'm gonna invest a couple hundred grand
into you and the stuff you're building
and if at any point you don't want to be
here it's probably better you just leave
because I don't want to waste any more
money
like if you don't want to be here
what so like what what am I supposed to
do with that you're going to be unhappy
I think it's a better structure overall
like again Hollywood it's cold in in
dehumanized because it's just a massive
Mega publicly traded Corporation dealing
with a bunch of creative idiots
very successful people sometimes but I
mean yeah you when you have a more like
a family-owned business you don't need
this super restrictive contract you have
leadership you have friendship you have
you know you can do things on a
handshake a contract is just in case the
worst happens you should be able to just
work things out do you think that
someone chatted Tim wants a volunteers
not hostages no that that yes I worked
for fusion and they had me under
contract then they went woke and I said
I'd like to leave and they said no
here's more money and I said this sucks
do you think that it's because it
doesn't scale like these kind of these
family-run smaller contracts they're
like I trust you let's let's work
together they don't scale because you
the owner loses contact with the new
hires because just because there's so
many employees yes I mean obviously as
you get bigger you're going to lose that
more personalized connection with your
employees and you know so it again it's
there's no one right way to do this in
in any way shape or form any of these
powerful voices you guys anyone else
it's do what you think feels right and I
think what It ultimately comes down to
what we're all doing this for is to help
save this country and save this planet
from tyranny and and this stuff is all
kind of on the side thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time